hi reject nation I'm Greg Alva and I'm
John did you guys see Mortal Kombat
annihilation it's the same exact thing
as this movie guys let's go into our
reasons to see and reasons not to see
movie review of Alex Garland's
annihilation it's for everybody
reason is see number one it's truly a
sci-fi film if you watch the trailer for
this movie there's a plot that they
present to it that there's some type of
meteor like thing that has some alien
thing that sort of crashes at this
lighthouse like there's this thing
called the shimmer which is this like a
big giant bubble it's established that
for a while now people have been going
in trying to figure out what's going on
cuz this thing is sort of just expanding
everyone who goes in doesn't come out
the setup of the main character of
Natalie Portman's character she's going
on this mission with four other women
are all like in the medical field in
some way yeah the seed is they've done a
whole bunch of military exploration and
they're gonna try it from the science a
yeah some when they're going into this
this thing called the shimmer that's
what the adventure begins basically you
know you start to encounter a bunch of
craziness a bunch of sci-fi wonders and
one is mutation and we say it's truly a
sci-fi film because there's a definite
plot to this movie and that's why I
think even if you don't fully grasp
everything about this movie I kind of
really like the matrix the matrix is a
film that sold a lot of philosophies a
lot of themes a lot of messages and
metaphors all those wonderful things
that sci-fi films do but you're not
really gonna grasp everything at what's
going on you're not really gonna go oh I
completely understand why this is
happening and why what's happening is
happening but there's always a plot to
keep you engaged and there's always a
plot to keep you onboard for what's
going on in front of you I never sat
there going I'm not interested at all
anymore we're supposed to a film like
mother mother is the kind of movie
that's really just about its point and
there's no real plot to it which I love
that movie but there's no real plot to
it here there's still a plot to keep you
engaged but it really is more about its
themes and messages and metaphors yeah
there's a linear unfolding mystery but
but so much of the charm is in thinking
and feeling it through and I feel like
this really is one of those movies where
once you reach the end of it you've
beheld at once as a complete whole then
go
back you'll probably get a whole lot
yeah I'll probably be able to see so
much more and think about it in
different ways from the trailer looks
like a sci-fi a horror of some kind
which it definitely has those elements
part of the thing that's so cool is that
it takes a more stark wears like mother
is very much you can a feel Aronofsky's
opinion about stuff through that movie
but it's also a very poking you kind of
movie and this one's a little more in
the middle where it's like you see the
horror and the beauty all at the same
time yeah and it's neither good nor bad
necessarily like that's that's another
layer it peels back on the Syfy's this
thing isn't just hostile it just is the
director Alex Garland he's been pretty
vocal about what he views his film to be
about even unlike non-spoiler interviews
and stuff without Scarlett when he's
talked about is how he really abused his
film as self-destruction we actually
just read an article from Collider a few
minutes ago where they talked about how
they think the whole film is actually a
metaphor for cancer and some people view
this as a metaphor about marriages I see
more of the cancer metaphors and the
self-destruction metaphor and they're a
little bit more clear about the
self-destruction one there's like
specific dialogue towards it yeah but
that's not really ruining the unfolding
mystery of the film for you guys that if
anything it might actually help your
experience if you know where what the
theme is going into it yeah there's a
lot of stuff is gonna feel random but
the more you pick it apart and the more
you immerse into it the less things are
actually random and that's a good thing
for first Ifill film especially because
there is so much that comes out that's
just neat or weird yeah and this movie
is definitely weird and and you know
once you get pretty deep into it it does
it's all calculated yeah totally and and
I appreciate again from Alex Garland
especially like he seems like he really
puts the time into making these even you
know these at least his two directorial
films now reason to see number two
directing cinematography and design yeah
all three kind of go hand in hand with
this movie tearing sound design in there
as well actually the directing of Alex
Garland if you've seen ex machina it's
even on a bigger scale here this is
technically a much bigger film than
something like ex machina but it still
feels contained it doesn't feel overdone
it doesn't feel over produced realistic
in the way that they
and I'll just the action of everything
yeah very along for this trip and the
designs of everything were so beautiful
it seems like they shot most of this on
location I think that's like I didn't
feel green-screen when I was watching
this they had like an arc like stories
afterwards and they're like specific
sets that were indoors I was like oh
they actually built that yeah they
enhanced it I thought it was I thought
it was just all green-screen but they
actually built it one thing about this
movie too that I think Alex Garland's
great at is he's really good at tone and
atmosphere yeah that's something that he
nails down here they say it's not
exactly a slow movie but it's not
exactly a fast paced movie I liberabit
yeah it's deliberate it takes its time
and it's the kind of movie that should
take its time and he also wrote the film
too so it goes without saying that like
the script is pretty solid as well it's
a thick film with a lot of themes on its
mind they also match to give you the
cool side of sci-fi as well like because
when there is the horror thriller stuff
it's not it's really here in the movie
but when it's there you remember it when
it's there it's suspenseful everything
is it's so specific so when there's
thrills it's thrilling when it wants to
take its time and be more emotional
peace it's really emotional feels very
lived in the ensemble gets along really
well yeah there's some of the
imagination like they've heard the word
unfilmable tossed around with the book
they really captured some stuff that by
the end of it blew me away in terms of
how they visualized everything how
everything feels very real fears like
it's on location some of those creatures
you see in the trailer are actual
animatronics and stuff but when you get
to the end there's some effects work
that blew me away it's the way that they
visualize these completely abstract
strange phenomena it's really impressive
on that level too as a sci-fi film it as
a visual depiction of sci-fi themes of
these visual metaphors and stuff because
we didn't mention it before the music is
really cool it's such an atmospheric
movies and it likes back and forth
between a scary-ass orchestra type of
score and then a cool guitar picking and
occasionally like just weird
inexplicable electronic sounds yeah cuz
I'm gonna music kind of memory of TT at
one point reason to see number three the
cast I think what made this film
especially impressive to me and why I
think that this isn't the kind of film
you could just write off as something
where
it's only about themes and messages and
metaphors and what not is because it's
also character-driven that's why I think
you can be an audience server who might
not fully grasp everything that's going
on there's certainly parts where I was
like okay I gotta look this up like the
credits roll of like I learned my phone
like there's some stuff I just don't
fully get I wasn't ever bored I wasn't
ever
I was always affected a big part of that
too is because of Natalie Portman's
character especially every character in
here all the girls the women in here and
Oscar Isaac included they're all
specific characters they all have
motivations they all have goals they all
have a reason to be there their dialogue
it's very specifically tuned to who they
are and Natalie Portman it has a whole
arc here has a whole journey here you
get all the points in the sci-fi heady
stuff but you also get a character piece
at the same time it's not a movie that
feeds you character development there
are some flashbacks here and there but
it's not like here's an info dump about
this personality a lot of it comes out
of their mannerisms and their
interactions with each other and the
subtleties of what each of them is
dealing with and their own destructive
tendencies and whatnot and that's
another thing is kind of beautiful is
just this cast really shines in this
movie reasons not to see it's just not
for everybody I see this as one of those
films that's more of film that if you're
like a movie buff or ass in a file or
loves those artsy pieces like weird [ __ ]
yeah you'll like this but if you saw the
trailer and the trailer alone and that's
what you're going off into this movie
for I could see why you'd have a hard
time being on board with it as a matter
of fact I saw one personally of the
theater and there's a couple next to us
who left the movie halfway through like
you heard their discussion of them just
going to enjoy this we got to get out
this week I was talking with John when
the movie was done I was like man I
could have used at least one character
to be like English please yeah that one
guy who just doesn't understand science
lingo in English please if you're saying
this to be alien but in a bubble yeah
weird messed up bear creatures yeah that
that character not here there's not
gonna be that character that way you can
get it expositionally explained to you
and in terms that a person who doesn't
really know science and whatever will be
able to really grasp because there were
a couple times I was like oh I kind of
wish that character was here for a
second yeah
I mean it is it is a bit thick and there
are characters there all scientists for
the most parts of there are times when
they are just using science jargon go
look it up but yeah I mean this is one
of those where I could definitely see
people being upset based off that
trailer cuz it does set you up for a
creature feature of some kind something
that looks like it's gonna be full of a
different kind of intrigue a more based
immediate sort of gimme intrigue and
like there is that stuff there are
creepy creatures and there are uncanny
weird unsettling things but they are
just it's not it's not you don't walk
away talking it's not about any money
shot ya know you don't walk away talking
about those things you walk away
thinking about what the movies about
dissecting and interpreting what's going
on and the thing is it's one of those
films that really challenges your
intellectual side it's not like the fun
grab popcorn and drinks entertaining
experience that you're probably open for
in February yeah yeah it's like it has
all that stuff and it will reward you
for you know meeting ya where it wants
to be this is for a patient movie goer
who will take the time to really try to
dissect what's going on yeah for sure
I really don't know where I stand on
terms of liking or loving this movie I
would I would definitely say that this
film has many multiple reasons to go
watch this film yeah watch it a second
time I'll see how I feel the second time
I watch it it's not one of those movies
where I can just fully grasp everything
that's going on the first time I check
it out overall I'd say that if you like
good sci-fi if you if you prefer the
kind of sci-fi that's really about
challenging your intellectual side and
really exploring themes of humanity and
whatnot this is the kind of film for you
but if you're just going in for thrills
it's definitely not the film for you
yeah I mean I gotta say everything in
this pretty much worked for me and it's
been a while since I walked out of a
movie and thought I really want to go
see that again not just because I had
fun or something but because I want to
see how this blossoms outward from my
first experience on the visual
standpoint on the acting standpoint if
you're just a fan of good films all the
physical elements are there to satisfy
you and if you like stuff that's a bit
out there a bit strange and that isn't
gonna just tie it up super nicely for
you definitely give this a shot yeah
yeah it's it's every eye for me this
movie is firing on all cylinders and
it's a treat to get this kind of sight
alright y'all just see annihilation did
you like it did you read the book and
hated this interpretation
did you see the trailer and hated this
movie it wasn't more than you expected
just give us your freakin opinion tell
movie subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell get
notified every time one of our videos is
up and check us out on patreon
full-length TV show music video
reactions over there weekly Q&A is a
whole bunch of goodies go check it out
you